hi everyone thank you for joining
back san luis just club's youtube
channel i'm wgm sabina foy sure
and today we are going to be talking
um about studies are more like it i've
prepared
some interesting studies with themes
of zugswang and domination and
i hope you guys will enjoy them today is
supposed to be
insane in the end game and studies are
those kind of
insane positions and i figured it would
be it would be awesome
to um you know select some nice
positions
and talk about them without further ado
i think it is time for us to get started
looks like we are live and everything so
[Music]
there it is what
what happened okay it's there i got a
little bit nervous
that my position disappeared all right
it's there okay so we'll start with a
simple study i think it's a pretty
famous
zugsvang position
and you know
i always found it interesting to
look at studies especially when you're
trying to
improve your calculation skills your
vision in space
and so on i think studies can help you
with that
specifically zugswang are i think are
some of the most beautiful
type of positions because you know
you're just making a move and then your
opponent suddenly has nothing to do
and um those are the positions that i
personally like
very much but if you know me you know
that i like
everything about everything so i
every theme is my favorite so hopefully
i will get to
um kind of
inspire you to to enjoy some of these
positions and chess in general
and this theme and
yeah so what do we have in this position
well clearly material if you were to
count it point wise
obviously it should be it is the same
but in most cases if we were to play
you know some normal move here with
white most likely the game will end in a
draw because
say we would just choose to capture the
spawn here with the king
and he would probably just
get his king out push the b pawn and
then
uh black should have no trouble making a
draw even if black loses all of those
three pawns right
rook and bishop versus uh versus rook
should be a draw
obviously but um it's
it's not always it's not always like
that of course
um many have
won or if they had the rook and the
bishop others have
lost with the rook obviously um
so anyways but okay theoretically it
should be a draw
so we're gonna try to find some way here
with white to
actually avoid that and we're going to
take advantage of this terribly placed
rook in a7 so for those of you who
have studied end games i mean
studies like endgame studies you know
that every single piece is placed there
for a reason and the fact that black has
all these
pawns around the rook and have their
rook trapped in a seven is certainly
going to lead to something dangerous so
in this position we're going to try to
keep that rook restricted first move
we're starting with is rook
h8 that's the correct move in this
position hopefully
you have all seen it picture 4 is an
interesting move i already mentioned
that taking the pawn does not quite work
but this is another move you can
consider and
because obviously he cannot go in the
corner because of mate so he's going to
have to go king c8
and you may think okay king c8 and then
i check them
he's going to go king d7 and then you
may think that
you're trapping the rook and you are
indeed
you can also try king takes a5 but if
you do so black has this
awesome move we're obviously threatening
bishop
sorry king b6 to trap the rook so he's
going to play king c6
and now if we try to trap the rook he
will give us this check
obviously we'll capture and then the
rook can just go out wherever it wants
probably
possibly on a light square you're
usually trying to place
your um your rook on
an opposite color than the opponent's
bishop and as i mentioned to you
previously
right um even if white gets to capture
those two pawns
this position should end in a draw
of course if you don't find anything
else if you were to play this position
and you don't find anything else
you should definitely go for this line
you're getting all of black's pawns
and you have some chances to um
make them suffer let's just say that way
for 50 moves if they know how to defend
great if they don't
then you'll get the chance to win
and then obviously um in d7
we can try [ __ ] up v8 but then of
course they go to k8
king c6 and
they still try to push the b pawn and
then of course go king b7 and try to
unpin them i mean
to take advantage of the pin if you move
the bishop they will trade rooks and
everything will be
awesome and then white will try to check
you
and then they could try to check you as
well you go there and take that pawn
and then now they supposedly got two of
your pawns and your rook is still
trapped there but really unfortunately
for white there's no
easy way to win here because now there's
king c8
attacking both pieces and after this
check
okay it is very important for black to
make the right move because it's very
very easy to follow for another trap
here
if you capture the bishop that's going
to be a blunder because of king b6 and
now the point is that
because blackstroke is trapped there
they don't have the opportunity to get
it activated
and because of that by the time they
push a5
white can just move this rook wherever
they want far away
and now they're threatening checkmate
and in order to escape that you're
either going to sacrifice your rook
or go king c8 and if you go king c8
oopsie
goodbye my friend and if you go
uh okay six obviously it's goodbye as
well
so that's basically
what is happening um so you would not be
playing this move instead you would go
king to d8
and uh now the bishop
is the one you know before it was
blackstroke that was trapped but now
somehow white got their bishop trap so
they have to go back you come back
and this is how the game would end in a
draw all right
awesome so bishop f4 may seem like the
right thing to do but unfortunately it
does not help white
to get to win the game so
they're going to have to change the line
a little bit
and now the beautiful thing is that we
are actually going to
stop black from pushing this pawn it
seemed that in all of the lines when
that pawn disappeared or black was able
to push the pawn
black was managing to escape with the
rook
and then you know there was no problem
for them drawing but now we actually
have this beautiful idea bishop d8 check
king c6
still now black is looking for ways to
push the b
pawn but now black has to meet this move
[ __ ] up to b6
which is really nice and now
if you capture now it is
a time to make that amazing move of
zug's bank that's why i'm saying that i
think
many of you possibly are familiar with
this
now this rook doesn't have any moves the
king still has moves on the c
file so what are we doing we're simply
restricting
the king from going on the c file and
now no matter what you do you're going
to lose
well you only have one move that's legal
basically okay 8 we capture it
and it is game over so this is basically
you know i think it was a pretty famous
position i wanted
all to start with to kind of introduce
uh you know the idea of zug zlang
obviously i believe many of you are
familiar with this but i felt like
it's nice to to have a simple position
to get started going on to the next
position now
this is my next position for you guys
and this is a little bit more
complicated but also
very very beautiful
and welcome everyone by the way this
is of course a live video so i'm really
excited to see
all of you here i hope you're enjoying
my theme of the day and the positions
that i chose
and you will stay with us until the end
of class
all right so in this position
yes so some nice ideas i can see in the
chat
basically in this position um if we're
counting the material because that's you
know one of those things that you want
to
kind of become familiar with when you
see a position first thing
is king safety but after that it's the
material
and sometimes the material comes in
first though you shouldn't consider it
first
ah always so tricky with chess players
anyways so white technically has an
extra point
because we've got three pawns and a
bishop
for a rook so that's really really
awesome
but black uh does have
you know the bishop the pawn under
attack ideas with king c6 and try to
take advantage of
some uh margin made
white pawns if you look at them they're
so weak they have
six islands of ponds every single pond
is an island which is
very very rare in general to see but
of course this is a created position
it's a study someone has created it it
was yanti man
actually for this one and
we have to think of some ways with white
to put our opponent in silk's line
to make a draw here shouldn't be a big
deal for white but to try to win
it's kind of important so i see some
people are saying king b7 and that is
indeed the correct move d7 is something
else you may consider doing but after d7
there's rook d8
and if that pawn falls it may not be so
easy
for white to come up with winning ideas
of course you know you can consider
grabbing that pawn but it's not really
helping you you have to try to keep
uh to take advantage of that pawn so in
order to promote it
you need to bring some pieces to support
it and since you cannot support it with
your bishop
bringing the king should be the wise
decision now
black has to move that rook and it's not
like you have tons of places d8 is the
only place you can
go with the rook if you just go randomly
somewhere like this just pretend here
then uh in this position white can just
play king c7
the point being that now white is
supporting the pawn to promote
right and then you know even if you take
the bishop it's not
helpful enough because we go d7 and you
don't have sufficient time to take all
of these pawns
there are plenty of pawns that white has
and black cannot take one to actually
have some counter play to promote or
anything
they are too far from this pawn for
example and so white promotes the next
move
wins the rook brings in the king wins
all these pawns
and then promotes the pawn so rook g8
does not work the only move
that keeps the position you know going
for black
is rook to d8 because it keeps the pawn
attacked
and pressured and um if
you go king c7 you're not really doing
anything because that pawn can be
captured by black so it makes no sense
that's the reason why after rook d8
white has to make a good move i wonder
if any of you can see it
after d8 because you do not want to give
up that pawn and this is something that
you have to keep in mind for end games
too
if you have a past pawn that
um is pretty advanced
that's kind of your strength and you try
to keep the pawn as much as possible you
don't want to let
to give your opponent the chance to to
take that pawn
away from you because that's the point
with which most likely you will have
the chances to to win
nobody's saying this move so i'm gonna
show it so the
beautiful move in this picture b4
bishop c5 rogue this uh you can't play
both of those moves before and bishop c5
you have to choose one
of those i see b4 and after capturing
bishop c5 that makes sense but why would
we give up that pawn right i just
mentioned how important it is
when we have a punch pawn like this we
don't want to give it up
and just because you're able to move the
bishop and protect the b pawn it doesn't
mean that this pawn is going to help you
create any kind of ideas that's not
going to work so well
besides black's king is close enough and
um
white will not be able to support to
push it forward with the rook and the
king they should be able to hold it from
pushing
so not before but bishop c5 in this
position
it's a beautiful and important move for
white
because
because now uh we're protecting the pawn
and if they capture the bishop which
they have to they don't really have many
choices where they're drinking c7
chasing the rook away
and then promoting the pawn and black
cannot bring their king in front to stop
it
so black has to take the bishop and now
we're playing c7
attacking the rook and black needs to
move it away
but if they move it somewhere on the
eighth rank d7 will be played even if
they go there right
i think if they go there maybe we can
play b4 first
check and then
whenever they move the king somewhere go
d7 and then because we want to have the
opportunity
for oops we're threatening promotion if
it goes king c6 for example we want to
chase the king away and if they give us
one more check we go king b7 and this is
a typical idea everyone should know
right
you're doing kind of a triangle with the
king in order to approach the rook and
if they get in front of the pawn then we
attack the rook the rook moves and we
promote
let's go after king c7 black should
capture the pawn
and now it is important what we are
doing
next we are going to play b4
check with tempo you cannot capture the
pawn
you don't have sufficient time in the
end game because your rook will be
captured and then white as i said will
win those pawns
and promote the f pawn and win the game
so black only has one move which is king
d5
and now it seems like white has made a
huge mistake
they gave up both a bishop and a pawn
and how are they going to save
themselves
you know to to um
to here how are they going to give save
themselves or can they even win i mean
that's crazy how can you believe you can
win here
this pawn is not even advanced but you
actually can
b5 this is the reason why white
gave up both that pawn and the bishop
because now white's
going with the pawn to promote and this
rook has somewhat stayed
trapped now the thing is if
black can kind of have two ideas to keep
the king in c5 to try to stop the v
pawn or go with the king to e5 both of
these moves are possible
if black goes king to c5 to keep her
protected
and threaten rook b6 and grab those
pawns what has this b4 pawn push
if you capture obviously you're still
going to be behind
after king e7 those pawns will be
captured and white promotes the f-pawn
while black's king is way too far
and if you don't do that and what else
can you do
you have to go back to keep your
protected
and now you may say oh and now it's fine
because now if white pushes here
they're going to lose because we give
them a check it's a checkpoint they have
to go there
and now we can just go somewhere like go
look back or something and then white is
not going to be able to
to promote like just think about this
line for example here here
here and you can think oh i'm going to
play king c8
and promote the next move but no king b6
and the point is that now if you go to
k8 there's a check
and rook a7 and then why loses that pawn
after which they lose the game because
they basically have a look down
so it's not as easy as it looks king c5
once again we go b4 all right
then he goes king d5 now we don't go b6
b6 would be a terrible
blunder so instead of that we'll go to
f4
and this is the first time you can
notice the
zuk's vlog because
now black does not have any place to
move their rook
everywhere they go is going to be
captured and the king cannot move the
king has been restricted
and has to stay on that square to keep
the rook protected therefore black will
only have h pawn pushes and will make
sure
that as soon as he pushes the pawn it
will be
located if black would have played h5
instead of h6
obviously we would have played h4 so you
have to
uh calculate your tempo tempes
well enough so that you know how you can
um
get your opponent to uh
you know to stay without tempes and then
they are the ones in subspine
all right so going back to b5 if black
plays king e5
something similar will happen we'll go
f4 once again not b6 because as i showed
through goes to d two and then they will
just
you know capture everything
all right and then after f4 the king has
to go to d5
and now once again we have the same idea
where we're restricting black's king
he has to start pushing the h pawn and
after
this move we have the same position as
before this is a zooks van
and black is it's over
this game over i hope you guys like this
idea i think it's
really cool how white gives up both the
bishop and the pawn
to stay with a technically a rook down
but they are able to actually win
not draw but win the game because of the
exam because blackstroke
ends up being trapped
moving on to the next position that i
have for you guys this is a little
bit more complex and
i'm curious if any of you have seen this
position before
or if they have any idea i'm glad you
guys like the like the positions i chose
i hope i've answered all the questions
even if i don't address one
in particular like as i see it but
i hope i'm answering as many questions
as you guys have
regarding the position so here i would
recommend
thinking a little bit on what you may
want to do with what
i know i know it makes sense what you
guys are saying
but as i was mentioning it is very very
important
to understand that um
studies end game studies
can help you very much become familiar
with themes
calculate better visualize better
and those things pretty much
uh that's pretty much that but i think
that's that's kind of big
even if you don't see it in an actual
game actually this doesn't
maybe the previous previous position you
couldn't see it in an actual game but i
believe
this one you could see in an actual game
because you could have lost an exchange
and
that black is you know close to
promotion and you have to think of a way
to keep them from promoting and you also
want to promote your c
pawns so there are always ideas that you
can come up with and stuff you can do
it's not so easy of course white wants
to promote their c pawn black
wants to promote their a pawn so how do
we you know
manage to do that i think in this
position
uh there are two moves that make sense
one of them would be king b7
to support the c pawn and the other one
would be rk6
the point of rook a6 would be to try to
win the a2 pawn but unfortunately
that's a mistake because exactly
exactly knight to b4 and attacking those
two
and then when you're capturing a2
because you know that's kind of the
point
then we take back and then here if you
come
uh if you get to play king b7 to support
the pawn
black can play bishop e5 and they're
stopping your pawn push
followed by knight before in case it's
necessary they even can sacrifice the
knight and the pawn in c6
and there won't be any way for black uh
for i mean no word there will be no
worry for black in that position
and white could not win that so rook a6
is kind of out of the question here
we have to find a way to support the c
pawn to promote
so the correct move is king b7
now what to do after king p7
we're threatening c7 black has to stop
us and the easiest way to stop us
is bishop e5 right by playing bishop e5
we stop c7 and we're
threatening to promote okay
now with white we don't really have a
way to support c7 yet so we're gonna go
to k6 now
the idea is the same as before we're
trying to stop the a pawn
but also we need to find a way to
support our c pawn but now without the
bishop in a1
obviously black is going to promote
a move like night here would not work
because obviously there's a threat too
which is okay a check and then it's you
put the bishop in to check me
so you have to look for simple things
like that too
and in studies i think you can see them
the best
or the easiest way anyways so queen
and the queen also stops rook rook eight
so we take
who are forced to take and then if
bishop takes c7 and it's game over so
knight takes
and now it is important to come up with
a good move with white because
we don't really have an easy way to push
c7
so we need to bring our knight somehow
in order to support that pawn push
and win the black special
the correct move is knight to d4
obviously they cannot take it
because of c7 they can take this h2 pawn
however
good job good job i see some of you are
actually
um suggesting this so after bishop h2
white now has this nice move f4 blocking
the bishop and if you capture it
then there's 96 check the king has to go
somewhere
and then we're grabbing the bishop and
black
is not in time now with the knight to
stop the pawn
although it may seem like he is
he is not now we can go c7
and then knight a5 check
king king there are many ways you can
you can play here um even king c8 works
because if the knight comes here
we just need to make sure that i cannot
go there because if it goes there
obviously we'll chase it away
um this pawn push will not work
and now black has maybe a check or two
but after this move
the pawn wants to promote black can try
to stop the pawn
but they are not in time look
because king b7 and because of one move
white manages to promote in time
before you got to promote the white is
winning
so bishop takes h2 does not seem to work
that's why in this position and very
important i want you guys to realize
that this knight restricts
this knight in a1 that's why my theme
for today is luxembourg and domination
because i feel
often times when there's dukesvang
at least one of the pieces of the
opponent has been restricted in such a
way that it cannot go to any square
i mean it can go but it's going to be
usually captured or
checkmated and that's why i feel like
zuzan and domination
are themes that are interconnected a lot
of the times
so now after knight d4 what to do with
black bishop d6
this is the other choice for them the
point is so that f4 does not come in
with tempo
so we're not forced to grab it if white
tries to make this move black can come
back
and now we're not dealing with the same
situation because you cannot really put
black in zug's land if you move this
knight
this knight will be free to go if we go
h4
black can play h5 and now it is white
who is in xbox
because if we play f5 his king can just
go here
and try to uh to kind of locate the pawn
and then if you're gonna play c7
that's what's gonna happen and then
we're threatening knight c toward knight
b3
giving up the knight grabbing that pawn
followed by king
g4 grabbing the h4 pawn and black should
manage to make a draw so please
be very careful on how you're giving up
your
mps you cannot give them up however you
want you have to be very careful
how you push the pawns in such a way
that
in the end you are the one with the
final tempo you play it
and then the opponent will be in zuzan i
have four once again with the same idea
if you captured there's 96
uh if you play h5 there's h4 and black
will be in zukxan
um and so black can try here
we go h3 right because as i was
mentioning
we need to make sure we're counting the
tempes whenever they go there we go here
and now it's time for black to move the
king they cannot go king e7 because
there's check
grabbing the bishop followed by home
promotion so black should try
instead to go king to e8
that way there's no chuck bishop and if
the knight moves
the bishop will capture an f4 followed
by the exit of this knight which is
something we're trying to avoid
so what to do here with white i think
the move is
kind of straightforward pretty pretty
nice c7
we're threatening promotion so he has to
take king takes and now you can suddenly
see
this domination once again this night in
the center keeps this knight in the
corner
that's why you're always told be careful
with your pieces try to avoid putting
them in the corner especially nights
and now if you try to keep the
opposition so there's no progress
we go in c6 and you may think you're
like you're doing the same thing as
before we're bringing the king to f6
sacrificing the knight with the idea of
afterwards going for the f
pawn and then king g4 and going for the
h1 as well
but it's not really working because
let's see here
king d6 or d5 actually both work
now let's say black sacrifices the
knight
and now it's time for you guys to see a
move
a very strong move for white
in order to be able to save
the game
well why am i saying save the game
basically save the game from draw
because white is winning here they have
a knight and an extra pawn
the correct move in this position is
knight to d4
and now king to e6 now white's king is
close enough
so by the time black goes to grab this
pawn
there is knight f5 protecting the pawn
the knight is protected by the king
and then the king marches grabs the h
pawn and white will be able to win
exactly
and this was the solution for this
position once again
i felt this was nice in a way as well
because it isn't a way forcing
but also you know keeping the opponent's
knights in the corner
is something you don't see so much so i
thought it would be nice to share it
with you guys
and another one
now i know many of you will tell me
about this position as well
it's by the same author pashtman or
parshman
i think many of you will tell me but
this is also not a position that can
happen in a game and
i totally understand you it makes sense
but you know what that's the beauty of
chess that's why it's an art and
everything
because you get to create positions and
you get to use your
you know knowledge in
[Music]
just simply simply chest knowledge in
order to solve positions
you come up with ideas you come up with
lines you calculate you spend time and
i don't know just i think it's beautiful
i hope you guys think the same
so what do we do in this position there
are so many past pawns of black
lag is also threatening promotion if
they do promote and
you don't have anything um
it's bad and yeah so
when i was teaching a few weeks back
for the beginners class i
did mention on a number of occasions how
important
it is to remember that if we are dealing
with
a promotion like a queen king and pawn
end game right where someone promotes
first
and then there's an a pawn or h pawn
on the second or seventh rank that gets
to promote
and then we can bring in the king to b3
right
to to uh to threaten the back rank mate
that i i made sure i let everyone know
that if
we are dealing with the rook it's not
the exact same situation
but as chess king is saying in the chat
um we are dealing with a different
situation now and black will not be able
to actually stop that mate
so this is the only idea that white can
utilize in order
to have some uh you know
have some chances here king to c4
ideas like you know rookie one or
something
will not work thinking that you i can
just go back and forth and i have a draw
no you cannot really do that because now
you go back and then black will capture
this pawn
and then they have a bunch of other
pawns that they can push forward
and you still haven't even won this
super advanced
pass pawn so this is something you have
to to remember and be careful for you
cannot
go rook e1 so we are going to go for
this and now
uh if black promotes to a queen in this
position
there's going to be king b3 and contrary
to what i mentioned
uh that i told you that i mentioned for
the beginners class
that if we have a rook instead of a
queen here
this idea does not work this idea does
not work indeed
but just in a queen king versus king
rook
end game in this position where there is
a pawn in before this idea works
perfectly fine because
rookie one is cheque queen and black
does not have
any more in this position with the queen
with which they can control the mate
okay so that's the the great thing about
the situation
so promoting to a queen does not work
promoting to a knight
doesn't make sense either because in
this position
uh there can be king c3 with a similar
idea of
grabbing all of those pawns eventually
that night will be
will be trapped and white will be able
to win the game
all right that's why in this after king
c4 black
is trying to find a way to save
themselves and how are they doing that
well very simple they are going c5 the
idea of this move is to get rid of the b
pawn so if you are so kind as to taking
now they will promote and then if you go
king b3
they will be like ha ha you didn't pay
attention queen there and
there's no mate okay so that's that's a
really big
there's a really big issue there um
because now they have the queen and they
will win the game
they will not let you escape trust me
that's why
you have to be wise too so we're not
going to take there we won't push the
pawn either because there
there's the same idea the whole point
for black is to get rid of that pawn so
there queen can stop the mate so we'll
go king b3
in this position
what's this uh what's the purpose of the
h
pawns we'll see we'll see in a moment
let's go through the line and you'll see
because you don't you know you can't see
a position be like what's the purpose of
this what's the purpose of that right
you
you can't see it until you're going
through the line and you
you uh realize what is happening and
then it makes sense
as to why those pawns or whatever pieces
are placed there
every single piece makes sense
so king b3 we're threatening mate now
promotion
but not queen knight because it's with
check
t4 check does not quite work because of
the same
idea we'll just capture it and then go
right back
and we still have this pawn here which
means that if black promotes
we're going to be three and there's no
way of stopping the bait
unless you sacrifice the queen after
which obviously white is gonna be
winning
super easily so black has to promote to
a knight here to make it with
temple king c3
she takes here king takes now this
knight is kind of trapped it cannot
really
get out i guess you could go night here
knight c2 but then the king comes in
and if you go back to to a1
usually this is the way that that you
win check
then you go there and then when you go
back
um we can start i mean white can start
giving a few checks and start grabbing
all these pawns first
and then they're gonna be able to win
if black plays b5 will go king c3 so he
hasn't managed to do much about
uh to to improve the position much with
this so
he's going to try h3
c3
let's see the beautiful one now check as
i was mentioning to you guys
this knight can never go away right so
that's why black has to start pushing
the pawns
king to c1 now look to a2
you have to be actually very careful
here because if you're going
rook h2 here oops
check check
and black manages to escape with the
knight from the corner and if this
happens
black would manage to make a draw so you
have to be very very careful to make
sure your opponent's night
if it's root versus night is going to
stay in the corner
so you have the winning idea so okay two
this is
important we're attracting the king to
go there and now rookie two
so what happened we are basically into
the same position
but now it is black to move so black has
to
start pushing their pawns that's the
point
we put them in xbox so they start
pushing the h
pawn all right so we're doing the same
thing this is the same kind of nice
maneuvering
okay two king b1 rookie two
and he can never move the king or the
knight so those pawns have to be pushed
and this line repeats itself over
and over and over and this is
basically kind of awesome uh because
what do you do now you still have to
push those pawns so you see
their plays there because they keep
pushing the pawns
and then the same thing
and at some point black will run out of
moves
right so he starts sacrificing these
pawns now we take them
obviously he's gonna sacrifice this pawn
too okay
and he's gonna try to escape with the
knight but no worries we go king c3 and
we know the knight cannot just run away
like that
how do you win if he just gives up this
is what we're trying to do
now his knight has to move somewhere
right and uh if he goes knight here
we take this pawn right he still escapes
with the knight as i showed you
previously
but the point is that here the knight
will get trapped after we take here
this knight is too far from the king
which means it will get trapped
and once again it gets trapped it will
be game
over it will be game over because
you'll just win the night
the name of the composer of the study is
written down stairs here it's
past one
so this is basically the point uh if you
guys want to know how you're winning
usually the way you do is you are
restricting the knight to keep
taking its squares away and you bring it
towards the other side of the board and
with the rookie restricted and then you
usually bring the king
to take it and they don't really have a
way so for example if this happens
you can go k3 for example
and then look here so you see how the
knight got restricted on each square
and then this will be the next move
usually this is the way it happens rook
kind of keeps two uh
two sides and then with the king you're
coming and you're trapping
the uh
the ninth if you're trying to go with a
knight here for example
something similar happens usually i mean
you have to be careful
how you do it i won't say it's easy it
depends but
you kind of have to think where the
knight will go next and try to keep it
restricted if it goes there you see
these squares are already restricted so
now you're thinking of a way to bring in
the king
and you can go for example king king
here
the point is if he checks you you can go
here right and you've
you've restricted its placement from
going there
and then you keep bringing the king and
eventually you will trap it it's way too
far from
black's king
i don't know if there was one moment
where someone had a question for example
if
in this position black would play b4 i
think someone was asking
but we're simply taking the pawn this
knight never escapes i want to
empha sorry emphasize once again what is
happening because
here after this
there's there's no easy way for for
black to
to to win i'm not playing this is
on youtube guys on youtube i'm only
teaching and showing positions and
showing them i'm not playing them
against anything if you guys want to do
that
uh i think it's cool you can always set
up the position and play it against an
engine if that is something
you guys want to but uh
when i when i teach the youtube lessons
i'm not
i'm not playing i'm just uh
showing the the solution
all right moving on to the next position
that i have
um i think these are really awesome
positions where
you're dealing with um
queens and minor pieces or you know
less valuable pieces trying to trap a
queen it's always really nice because
you see how it actually dominates how
those pieces actually restrict the queen
and that's something
you don't often see so it's it's kind of
important to keep that in mind
all right so what do we do in this
position with
white black's king stays on some kind of
mating ideas the queen
is somewhat trapped and with white we're
trying to find a way
to keep that king that queen sorry
restricted
so that it doesn't have ways to bother
us
i wonder if any of you guys has an idea
on how we can
keep that queen restricted
and with knights just keep that in mind
with knights
you always have the possibility to um
you always have the possibility to
have like check queen patterns and with
the rook tool like skewers
so knight g3 and knight d6
are the options that i see rook g8 to
stop queen f8
i guess that works too queen rook g8 but
there's also queen f4
check this is kind of a more annoying
threat i would say because that's a
czech knight
and you would lose your knight and you
don't want that and there's also queen
takes h5
check and you would lose the pawn and
then it's not so easy so you definitely
need to start with a check here
the correct move is 96.
now black doesn't have so many options
so we can consider more of them but it's
really
not so easy for example if he goes king
e6
makes sense king here does not work
because there's a check queen
so we're easily escaping that move kinky
six or king f6
those are the two moves that make sense
here in this position i think we can
tracking e6
uh but the point is now we're giving one
more check
and now regardless of where they go
there's going to be a big issue so for
example if they go king
f6
we have a very very strong move with the
white
that we're taking away all of the
squares for the queen and we're putting
them in zugfang
the correct move here is rookie five
the queen cannot take the knight the
knight is protected by the pawn so if
you take it
you would lose the queen so you don't
want that
and the point is that now the queen has
no moves if he goes there there's check
queen
if it goes here there's a check queen
it cannot move to g6 or take the pawn it
could take this one but there's a check
queen
and black also cannot really move the
king here because there's a check queen
so this rook rookie five move is putting
black and zuksan
and there's nothing nothing nothing that
they can do
um king of six we've said
uh king d7 for example there's
this beautiful rookie seven check if the
king goes there there's a cheque queen
if the king captures the rook we have a
check queen over here
and king d5 i guess is the last move
that makes sense but we have
exactly the same pattern because we
either get the check
queen there or check queen here based on
where
where black goes if it takes the rook or
goes king to d4
so that's the reason why and then king
e5
there's knight f7 of course so knight d6
is a really strong move and king e6
doesn't seem to work because it
helps white bring the stroke on a good
pattern and
yeah that rookie 5 move is just amazing
i think
so after king f6 now it is important to
come up with a good move
and once again as i was saying the rook
and the knight
together they are able to create these
um
forking ideas and um
double x-clam indeed lots of ex-slam
so now there is rook to g5
i love this move so much once again kind
of hanging
exactly on mario yes just hanging the
rook
but you cannot do anything if you bring
the queen to f8
oopsie cha queen
if you take the rock oopsie check queen
and if you take the rook with the king
obviously same thing
so this does not oh and by the way the
king of pawneen game should be winning
i need to show it to you but uh we're
gonna go d4
and then he brings in the king and then
d5 and
even if you go there then there's going
to be d6 this pawn is protected and
white can just win that pawn after which
they win the game
so that's something important to
remember the king and pawn in game
is winning
that's why in this position after rook
g5 black's
only move is king e6 with this move
they're trying to
free a square for their uh queen
and then um
well that's what they're trying to do
basically just free square for the kin
and also threatening to take the rook
so now again you need to come up with a
good idea
no no these are studies yes
the name that you see at the bottom is
the name of the composer of the study
that's why i'm not giving the black
blacks name because there's no
no player for black pieces today's
today's lesson is as as the title says
study time i decided to name it
focusing on xbox and domination because
you can clearly see how
you know specific pieces are restricting
other pieces
of the opponent rookie 5 once again
indeed
that's the correct move here and then
we're back to the previous position
we've seen if the king captures this
knight f7
uh if the king goes to d7 there's a rook
there check
and if the king goes to f6 now it is the
time to
to come up with something
with a nice move for white
king to e2 this is a gorgeous move i
love this move
so much once again
because we're protecting the pawn which
is a
pawn that black was considering
capturing um
and the queen still cannot move
on any of these squares if it goes to f8
there's this if it goes there there's
this
uh and now basically what you're doing
is you're just defending your pawn so
that they can't capture that
however when we make this move we do
give up this f4 square so you can
say ooh deco queen f4 and what do we do
after this move
well we still have rook f5 check as you
guys remember
we can enter into this king and poland
game but this king opponent game
is winning i'm glad you guys like it
now king e3 and then white follows up
with d4 d5
creates their past spawn and wins the
game
so all of these moves i just felt like
there's
great moves rook g5 rookie five king e2
all these putting this the opponent's
king in
uh or all of their pieces on
in zugspun no moves nothing to do
and the game gets to be over king e5 for
example we got d4
check and even if you go here we'll just
play h6 if we want to
to make sure the king goes back and then
our
king goes forward and then d5 and
we're winning um i know lots of people
get
nervous about these types of situations
because if you do create the past pawn
you think it will be a draw because
but no it's not a draw even here you go
d5
and now white manages to win by one
temple because black cannot
keep them shouldered there's king g7
and white wings of course all of this
has to be calculated to make sure
you know you guys actually are winning
but yeah all right and uh
this may be our last position
that we're doing we're solving for today
it is white to move
and this is a troisky position triscuit
is a very famous
chess composer that many of you
hopefully have heard of you
this is about domination
only domination
so what we notice here is that
um white stroke is attacked
and if you were to just move the rook
somewhere you don't really have a place
to because you can't put it there they
will take it
and the point is that if you click it
anywhere they promote so this is pretty
serious
this pretty serious stuff you need to
come up with a good idea for white
and it gets to be somewhat forcing the
first move at least knight a5
check because while they're putting your
opponent
king in check it cannot promote or do
any other thing that they may want
exactly
so what to do king a7
if he goes king here you just take
check ruby one and we've stopped
black's h pawn which is very very
important
yes attempting to set up the arabian
weight indeed
if he goes king to b8 in this position
is the same thing right rook b6 followed
by ruby one
stopping the h pawn and white will be
winning after that
because they have an extra rook so king
a7 is the move
to look out for because it doesn't let
white bring in the rook
to stop that past pawn
rook c7 king 8 rook c8 king a7
and it may seem like you don't really
have more than a draw
you can repeat the position but your
rook will never manage
to stop that age pawn in time there's no
way
so you can say you know what i don't
care i will let you promote
but obviously you won't just say that
you actually will have a very clear idea
as to what you will do
so that you know this will not just be
game over for you
what to do now with white
now we will just move we will just move
our rook somewhere
and that correct square is b8 we're
threatening to promote
this is where we see domination so we're
threatening to promote
he's gonna be like what are you doing
this is a check i'm winning the pawn
what are you talking about right
but white has a clear idea in
in mind uh oh
white has a very very clear idea in mind
i wonder
if you guys can find it so the arabian
mate indeed
how do we get to do it now he took
our super strong pawn i was mentioning
you guys earlier when you have a past
pawn about to promote
you are gonna keep keep it with your
teeth you are not gonna give it up
just like that unless you see something
better
unless you see an idea with which their
pieces will not do much
after winning your pawn but rp7 check
indeed
and then oh not knight c4 but knight c6
indeed
knight c6 beautiful move threatening
mate
both in b8 and a7 and black cannot take
because their queen is hanging
and black's queen doesn't have any
checks that make sense
right because we're threatening one of
those mates so the only choice that
black has in the position
is to take the queen right but when they
assert the rook
when they take the rook there's a check
queen and there's nothing to do
it's kind of crazy don't you guys think
so rp8 just hanging the rook
but you're threatening to promote and
there's
really nothing nothing nothing that they
can do other than chuck
has to do this check and this is again a
very important move because you're
maintaining your knight on the right
square
to bring it to have that arabian mate
and now you're threatening promotion he
cannot grab the knight because you're
just promoting and there's nothing they
can do about it
and um yeah and then if they take it as
i mentioned there's a check
and rook c6 if they take the the rook
obviously we take the queen and there's
no
nothing else that black can actually do
in order to save themselves
because uh after 1960s me
so this these were the positions
that i came up with i mean i didn't come
up with sorry there are studies that i
took uh from from
uh studies book i felt that they were
interesting
uh the theme is really awesome i feel
like domination
and zugzwang as i mentioned at the
beginning of the class
uh are very important themes that happen
in real games too
and i really hope you guys enjoyed my
selection for today
i'm so glad you guys like it appreciate
you joining in
be sure if you enjoyed this video be
sure to
give san luis chess club
follows or sorry subscribe on youtube is
subscribe
be sure to subscribe so you get notified
whenever we go live
or we post new videos the club is
posting
so much uh interesting material that i
think
many of you will not want to miss if you
like this video also thanks for giving
it a thumbs up so that
uh we create more of these
have a wonderful rest of the evening
or morning depending on where you are
i'm looking forward to seeing you
all very very
soon stay tuned for more
tomorrow bye guys
you